- Yeah, I just finished a
Harvard Business case study,
which is gonna be exciting,
and now I'm walking into the 4Ds.
I'm not wearing any
shoes, 'cuz fucking Tyler
told me I had sneakers, and then I didn't.
Hey
- (group responds)
- Hello!
Hello, hello, hello!
♫ Still dreaming like this
world ain't against me
♫ Like my skin tone different
♫ Like Pops was always around,
♫ Like wasn't nothing missing
♫ I ain't tripping, I know
some people had it worse
♫ But just 'cuz it's common,
that don't lessen my curse
♫ And for my dawg behind
the wheel as we speak
♫ With bread set aside,
♫ But you be working like you can't eat
♫ Keep dreaming, dawg, keep dreaming
♫ I know some days you wanna
go from planning to scheming
♫ Ya, yeah
- Going to speak to the peeps right now.
I just had a cool job interview.
Forget about everything else,
do you know why we're gonna win?
Because I don't care
about making any money.
(elevator dings)
- (Man) Poor April, that one guy.
- This is a no-brainer.
You know, I forgot about this model,
'cuz this was stuff I learned
about, like years ago.
Dude, you're, this is good.
I'm fucking pumped.
Do it fucking every
day, in your underpants
in your fucking living room.
Have more people own the
fucking data, have the data.
They become your leads, not
some fucking random numbers
that called in to some ...
Like, it's crazy better.
I have to exploit this, this is insane.
That was nuts.
- (Man) That was nuts.
- 4Ds has, like, been
such an incredible ...
I wish I could, you know, sometimes in my,
like, darkest moments of Vayner,
I'm like, I'm gonna sell
Vayner and just do 4Ds,
just, like, spend 18 hours
a day with businesses,
and just fucking jam.
It'd be so, so f ...
I mean, I love it.
Yeah, man.
I love how, I love,
you know what I like?
I like the historical impact, right?
Because I'm always
looking for those trends.
I think, such a young
group, every one of us
will see two sports that don't even exist,
or, are, like, in some
weird sub-culture right now
that are gonna be mainstream, right?
I mean, when you think
about where eSports,
soccer, and UFC is today,
compared to where they were
when I was 21 years old, 20 years ago?
Either non-existent, couldn't
even think about it existent,
or it's never gonna happen here, right?
UFC was banned, soccer will
never happen in America,
and eSports fundamentally did not exist.
I'll talk to you later.
- (Man) Gary!
- Yes.
- (Woman) I'll send you an email.
- What's that?
Of course!
Adrian, you want to get in?
- (Adrian) Yes
- Awesome
- Thanks, man!
- Such a pleasure, nice
meeting you, what's your name?
- (Sanjay) Sanjay
- Sanjay?
- (Sanjay) Pleasure, let's meet up.
- Yes, love it, see ya!
Really good, great talk.
I felt really good about that.
- (Man) Yeah, man.
- You know, obviously I love,
as you guys know on
YouTube, I love sports.
Fun to come, sorry,
D-Rock, let me get here.
Fun to come to the NBA,
great, great business executives,
sports, like Fan Dual.
You know, just great
setting, a lot of fun.
I got going, there,
there's some good stuff.
♫ What the hell, what
the hell, what the hell
♫ Ooh, what happened to
ambition in some older place
♫ And education for a
graduation not a stay
♫ Stop the blaming, you were
lame and you should be ashamed
♫ Well, you played the
game that ain't for fame
♫ So I'll put you back where you came
♫ It's Omid, that's my first namesake name
♫ So move over, I am coming
for my place in the mainframe
- D Rock, turn around.
YouTube, a little learning moment,
talking to Tyler about some strategy.
I say something about experience,
D-Rock starts laughing,
and it's just funny to watch both of them.
It's unbelievable what seems hard today
becomes so easy when you actually do it.
It's unbelievable, it's
like working out, actually.
It's like, 80 pushups?
Reps, fucking reps.
- (Tyler) Fucking reps.
- Like, just watching you
be able to handle way more, easier.
And, you know, you, too.
It's just probably how
I got here, right, like,
20 fucking years of reps, you know, reps.
20 years of fucking the
responsibility on my neck.
It's how I eat shit all day.
Better start eating shit,
it's how you get paid.
Okay.
So-
- (D Rock) So-
- (Justin) Welcome to the
block, you're the fucking man,
and a local hero.
- Thank you, Justin.
Real pleasure, man,
thanks for setting us up.
- My dad, from The Wine Library-
- (Gary) Yes
- Also thinks you're the fucking man.
- Thank you, Brother.
Tell him I said, what's up.
- (Justin) Good job, man.
- Thank you, man.
(audience laughs)
Oops.
My man, you did a great
job, that was a lot of fun.
- Appreciate it-
- Thank you.
- Appreciate it, yeah.
- I appreciate your work.
- (Man) You're gonna
be hyped for this one.
- Yeah, I think this'll be a good one.
When do you guys air it?
What up, YouTube?
Say hello.
- Hey, what's going, YouTube?
GaryV-
- Tell them, tell 'em.
How'd it go?
- He killed it.
- How many guests have
you had on this show?
- Uh, like a hundred.
- And am I the best
guest of all time, now?
I mean, is it pretty obvious?
- In a-
- What do you think?
- Stratosphere all your own, here.
- Like, seriously, on a very serious note,
what do you think?
Like, rank me all-time on this show.
- Top three.
- Who are the other two?
- Uh, TJ Miller, I really liked.
- Okay, and?
- I don't know, there's always-
- Top two, top two, fuck you, TJ!
(audience laughs)
Thanks, man, take care.
- Alright, bye, Dude.
Yeah, you, too, man.
- See ya.
Oh, sorry, Hawaiian
shirt, what's your name?
- Bill.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you, man.
What's up, Sis?
The Sis is in the house!
- (Woman) What department are you in?
- I'm in Ad Ops.
- (Woman) Oh, that's right.
- She's just hiding, she's not doing shit.
She, like, hides in the
corner, makes pretend,
just gets paid.
That was good, what do you think, D Rock?
All right, let's go.
I know it's a nice family reunion,
but let's get the fuck out of here.
You can see I'm getting better
with the vloggy stuff, right?
That's why you've been
down on the last two,
because I've been so busy
I haven't been able to do anything.
Two, see it?
Some people see "network," I see "two."
This is why I win: I see
different things than people see.
Seriously, it's a real insight.
- (D Rock) I see "joy," not "enjoy."
- D Rock, don't rip off my, ah, this guy.
I see, I see a rat!
(laughs)
Can you get me '94 Madden?
Who's this?
Nobody's supposed to be
calling me right now, right?
- Uh, yes.
- Who?
- It's a podcast, Brams, sport network.
- Yo, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you?
This feels like a pretty
safe place to do it.
I've been very disappointed
by media companies
who were always trying to figure out
what am I going to do for
you when I put out this show,
or this article, or this radio show,
and then when it came to
social, to your point,
follow me, follow me,
follow me, follow me.
I get why, it was the
first time we put numbers
as a public domain, it's a badge, right?
How many followers you got?
How many, I get why it happened.
It's why I'm so glad it happened,
because I was able to see through that,
and I was hacking the game
that actually mattered,
which was depth, not width.
I mean, it's even this,
what the hell am I doing
on your show right now?
Like, everybody in my world is like,
this is not a good
allocation of your time.
We've got businesses to run,
you've got bigger shows that are,
you know, I'm saying no to
CNBS and ESPN every day,
and I'm here with you right now,
because I like serendipity,
I like building depth with
people on the come up.
I like that you're going to be able
to use my name to book
bigger guests in the future.
I like Karma, I think it's practical.
I think audio's gonna explode,
so I think podcasts are
gonna explode even more so.
Alexa's skills, I think Amazon
is going to become a major player.
I think Amazon is the one
that could probably create,
if I heard today Amazon A has launched,
and it's a new social network called A,
I would be, like, hey, this has a shot,
just 'cuz I believe in the people, right?
So, I think there'll be one or two things
five years form now that everybody is on.
And definitely in the youth.
I think that somebody who's
eight years old right now
in five years, will be on an app every day
that does not exist.
I never eat lunch or
breakfast, and here's why.
- You're tired.
- I'm, like, tired, I'm
like fuck this food.
Like, no wonder all of
you don't work that much;
you eat lunch.
What's up?
- Doing well?
- Doing well.
City bikes, they're bikes, D Rock.
I'm just gonna run around New York City,
"Guys, we have an alert!
"Found some real pinot grigio!"
She loved it, she loved it.
Guys, we did it, we
found real pinot grigio!
Anybody looking for
some real pinot grigio?
Hey, you looking for that
real pinot grigio? (laughs)
- (Man) Gary, what's up, bro?
- (Gary) Hey, brother, how are ya?
- Everything good?
- Everything's good, you?
- Good to see you, keep it up, man.
- From yelling about pinot
grigio in the streets of New York
to going to one of the largest,
most conservative companies in the world.
♫ Get back, it's so
bad, I'm about to hijack
♫ Yo, for jack, don't be
mad, you a tad late to be-
- I certainly can't walk, and think,
and talk, and sign
something at the same time.
- (Woman) And smile.
- And smile.
- (Woman 2) And smile, and now.
- How come you have two mics?
- Because I do a daily vlog.
- Oh, okay.
- I am double-mic'd often.
- (Tyler) Very often.
- D Rock, get in here, let
me get a photo with you.
Good to see ya.
- I'm a huge fan.
- Thank you, brother.
- It's so cool to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Dude, I watched all your videos,
and it really inspired me.
- Thank you, brother.
- We're gonna get started
- Might as well, right?
- You winked at me, and everything.
I feel like we're old friends.
- I know, right?
- So far, so good.
- So far, good start.
Awesome, man, thanks for coming.
I'm about to go do this talk
for Cornell Tech, and Bloomberg.
Super excited, great vibes, good crowd.
Old friends, life is good.
- Old friends.
(audience claps)
- Thanks for having me.
(audience laughs)
- Have you thought about
monetizing your voice?
That's incredible.
- (Man) If you can give
me two power moves,
to consumer attention, because you have
basically mastered the art of video.
Everybody and their mother watches you.
So, if you give me two power moves
that you can use in the next 24 hours
to getting consumer
attention, what would they be?
- I would become
disproportionally educated,
or start practicing very aggressively
in understanding how Facebook ads work.
Facebook ads are so good.
You can create long-tail clusters,
42-year-old Latino women that
like the New York Jets, okay?
Now, go make a video.
Go make a Spanglish video about the Jets,
like, the ability for the
micro target at scale, right?
Like, I have a video that went berserko,
which was, it was
basically, I was getting mad
that no 44-year-old thought
themselves as an entre ...
Like, I was watching all
the 19 and 20 year-olds
with all these
opportunities, and I'm like,
Jesus, where are all the
40, 50, 60 year-olds?
Have you heard, you're going to be living
longer than you think.
Like, let's go get ours, right?
So I made that video, and it went crazy,
because I targeted 40 to 60 year-olds
that watch Shark Tank.
(audience laughs)
There's so much capability in that.
I'd also, you know, look,
I've got gift for gab,
you've got crazy voice.
Like, you've gotta be smart about that.
The first three seconds really matter,
the copy really matters, the
thumbnail really matters.
Everything matters.
I love how people think these people
who have amassed millions of followers
because they got lucky, you know?
There's so much thought
that goes into what we do.
A lot of testing and
learning, but Facebook video.
YouTube is hard to break out, very,
Facebook video, less hard,
especially if you have a
couple hundred bucks per video
to try to get it to go.
(camera clicks)
Heading to see Ben Leventhal, CEO of Resy.
His babysitter just canceled, so,
instead of the restaurant,
we're going to his apartment.
So, great day, super enjoyed today.
Lot of good content for you, D Rock.
Big day for D Rock.
And YouTube, big love,
love all of you guys.
Keep grinding, keep hustling.
You know all the cliche
shit, but most of all,
figure yourself out.
♫ Yeah, my focus, eyes closed
♫ This has set the tone
♫ No limit that used the
sky is the stepping stone
♫ Lately I've been
thinking more speaking less
♫ My lungs empty, but I still
feel less stress I'm blessed
I don't give a fuck if fucking
Randy, the Macho Man, Savage
came from the death, went on my sock,
and then came back to
life and did two channels.
As my favorite person of all time,
rest in peace, Randy Savage
- (Man) Yeah.
- I wouldn't give a fuck.
Please, never, I mean
that was such a ridiculous
thing to say to me.
You know me so well, what the
fuck's the matter with you?
I'm not even gonna do anything, I'm done.
I'm not even gonna expand on it.
I'm just disappointed in you.